right now I want to call in actually I'm
gonna call there's a lot of you guys
follow barstool or know about them one
of their writers who I performed with
him Boston Francis Ellis just got let go
by them and I want to give them a call
right now to find out a little bit more
about what happened because it's really
interesting to me big Francis I'm doing
good man you sound unemployed I do know
you don't make you sound good I'm just
joking I feel good I feel good I don't
know I don't feel unemployed but I am
well you just kind of I guess kind of do
you feel set free like what kind of
happened with the situation it seemed
well what happened with the situation
sure
on Friday I wrote a blog about a girl
who had missing for a week the headline
that I saw was that her sorority sisters
had seen her Instagram was active so
there was reason to hope and then I read
a headline that said that authorities
didn't suspect foul play
I thought that meant she was kind of
okay in my mind that meant good news
yeah yeah and I didn't even really think
about what was actually happening and if
you read the blog I wrote I wasn't
making fun of her I was kind of just
lazily saying you know here's the story
she's also a fan of a podcast we have a
barstool hopefully though you know when
she turns up okay those girls can send
her some merchandise yeah yeah checked
it out yeah and you know I think that
the tone and the timing were what really
made it so so bad and and so careless
and and just a major oversight on my
part and very thoughtless and it came
off kind of heartless and they had to
let me go and I totally understand their
decision so mmm
yeah I mean III I've been following that
case pretty close like I mean as much as
I could just in the news you know
checking up a couple times a day and
seeing what was going on yeah I guess I
guess like you said the timing and the
tone but don't you think like do you
feel that like an apology I mean it's
like obviously if I listen to you right
now talking about it it's very obvious
like what happened like you you know you
misjudge what was going on
you fat you know you were taking things
from the news stories and yeah you
weren't mean you weren't malicious and
you just kind of made that guess kind of
an accident
I did I think you know it's very
important to note that what what my
intention was which was not to somehow
disgrace the memory of a girl who had
lost her life yeah of course not was it
was to sort of I guess highlight a major
news story that I thought was developing
in a different way and my my big fault
was that I should have been I should
have read more about it and realized
that regardless of what the outcome was
this was still a situation I should not
have touched upon and of course a couple
hours after I wrote it they've been they
announced that they found a suspect and
then it started really looking hard you
know horrible from there yeah and that's
when I took the blog down and I was I
realized my how just awful my mistake
had been so yeah do you think like but
do you think that most people are like
understanding in and can can forgive you
like I mean most people yeah like I even
when I read it I was like oh man France
is just sitting kind of realized what
was going on this was a mistake but you
know it's things happen and and that's
and that's that yeah I think I was
actually kind of made I was I was
encouraged by the response to my mistake
because I thought I have we live
in this world where there's a lot of
outrage and you know people equate a lot
of mistakes and behavior under one like
lump problem right but at people the
overwhelming response showed that people
are able to differentiate between
people's mistakes and they didn't put me
under the same category as you know a
Harvey Weinstein or they named your your
problem and Alyssa Milano sure I don't
know I don't know what's good I didn't
even know she just yeah she just won't
shut up all the time um but no I feel
you though like well this but yeah it
seems to me like most people can
differentiate and it's like so why does
it seem why do you were you shocked at
like your employers have to go with you
know a couple of blogs that you know
that nobody maybe even reads writing
something I think barstool understands
that by being a writer there I have I
have privilege in an obligation to be
more careful there are so many eyeballs
it's such a big platform and such a gift
to be able to write there that you have
to be careful and you have to be better
than I was you know I hate to say it but
like that that blog I wrote what was not
even I wasn't it was a lazy blog in
every sense of the world I see what
you're saying it wasn't like something
that I would have hung my hat on or been
like this is good work it was just
something I wrote to like show that I
had come to work that day I say and um
and that's just unacceptable especially
with that subject so I totally
understand
Dave Portnoy decision to say you know I
that I had abused the platform they gave
me I made the company look bad and name
for it you know by by losing my job so
I get it and uh it's it's fair to me
mmm wow man it's a lot of ownership by
you man I think it's really um it's
really remarkable even here just hearing
you say that like you know to recognize
your own part in things no matter what
the outcome even if you even if inside
of yourself somewhere you felt the
outcome was just or wasn't just like
just to recognize your own part in it
and I mean it probably gives you a
little bit more of a place of power than
or
comfort than a place of just sitting
there like with your head between your
your hands yeah cuz you're like one of
the most talented guys man I mean I
think you're so talented so charismatic
and I think Dave even said that I you
know watched his Instagram video do you
think that if if barstool wasn't owned
by like a larger company that they that
that this still would have been the case
or do you think that you know do you
think that that plays like a bigger role
just not just into like overall like
decisions that have to be made like oh
we're part of a bigger group now so this
is some you know there are other voices
that influence right it's a good
question and one that a lot of people
have asked me and honestly personally
it's a lot healthier for me to just not
question it very much and to just know
that I screwed up and that it's on me
and that I could play the what if game
in so many different ways right if what
if she had turned up alive and was fine
like would I be in trouble into the same
decree right um and what if you know
they hadn't if barstool hadn't been the
controversial company that it is right
would I have been dealt with the same
way I can ask so many questions but the
bottom line is I did something really
stupid and in a professional setting
when you work somewhere there has to be
consequences and if this is the
punishment that they decided to fit the
crime
I I stand by that I stand with them and
I I'm only grateful for what they
provided
for all those years and I can live with
it you know yeah well I mean you're a
champ man no it's just it's such a you
know it's such a on word like moving
forward positive way to to interpret to
interpret it all no matter no matter
what it's like just accepting finding
your role in it look I've
I kind of was I could have been you know
I have a platform I was just trying to
do something that worked that day I
didn't do as much of the background
stuff as I could have just knowing that
you didn't really rise to the occasion
as much as you probably should have and
so therefore even though it got out of
control after that that there were some
consequences yeah exactly and I think
look you know we're comedians if anyone
out there actually thinks that I was
writing a piece in an effort to disgrace
or mock no one does who had lost her
life like that person that's crazy
yeah course not I'm no one is I don't
know anyone that you know and you know I
think when you have that many eyeballs
as I said you have to be a little bit
more careful and a little bit more
professional yeah I just dropped the
ball and that's what it was yeah yeah
it's tough too cuz also you're in an
environment where like you know barstool
there's this whole vibe there where it's
not kind of professional and it's not
organized but at the same time it is
very much so it's like yeah so it's I
mean this is such a tough space almost
to really live in a little bit um to
embody the brand but at the same time to
recognize a you know a responsibility in
a place that almost thrives on pushing
kind of irresponsibility in some ways
yeah I think exactly and I think you
know I had a lot the one thing that was
so amazing about working a parcel is
that they give you so much liberty to
create your own work to come up with
your own ideas to act on your own
comedic impulses
and um you know you don't always get it
right like sometimes you're not funny
sometimes you're just stupid and
sometimes you're really offensive and
unfortunately I think all three were the
case working against me
that dirty trifecta bruh
yeah exactly the old bowling Turkey oh
yeah trying to speak the oven language
and I can't oh yeah but you know it was
one of those things where I had I had or
their respect and Trust in that I would
put out my own work and it would not be
problematic because I had writing for
there long enough that they said okay
you're you're independent you're on your
own
we we don't need to hold your hand
anymore yeah cruise control Cana yeah
exactly and then you know you just just
one morning you kind of come in and yeah
yeah you don't have you don't have it on
yeah I don't know how else to put it
like I looking back I don't even
understand what I was thinking mm-hmm
ridiculous yeah yeah I guess in
hindsight it seems it's almost like a
bizarre thing and even kind of get into
but but I think that's you know like
that those the websites and stuff like I
mean you know here in Los Angeles you
hear all you know so many women like you
know screaming about feminism and you
know and just a lot of violent feminists
out here as well but then you see these
literally on on every other billboard
you'll see a sugar baby or a sugar daddy
website which is you know I don't think
those websites a lot of men that I know
they're on those are you know are sick
man or troubled men who are just using
women for sex and not even giving them
any any money or any it just seems like
a scary place and I guess you know that
element of the story unfortunately it
was something that I did include but I I
was reading off of all the websites and
every story was talking about her
involvement on those oh yeah
daddy things and it was like you know
ABC News like I didn't I didn't bring
that to light and I didn't I there was
one news source that said that I are
like one article that said that I was
slut-shaming this guy and that I mean
that is so that is such a ridiculous
ridiculous dish if you look at the blog
in no way did I ever say like oh no she
she's a bit a bless her person for
having been on these websites I I think
I just included it because maybe they
thought that that was one of the things
that might have been why she was missing
ya know a hundred percent look at and
it's a scary place it's a scary place
for interaction especially when you're
you know when the product a lot of times
is such an intimate product it's like
you know if you're gonna meet somebody
to buy shoes you could do that out in
the front yard but if you're meeting
somebody to engage in you know romantic
engagement see whether it's a massage or
just sitting there watching television
together or even sexual endeavors it's
gonna be behind closed doors so is a lot
it's it's very very spooky and sometimes
I worry that a lot of the you know some
of the like a lot of young women they
you know they say you know they hear all
this body empowerment you you know you
control your own sex and this and that
and which is true no doubt but the fact
that some of these young ladies could be
misinterpreting that and thinking you
know okay well you know I don't need to
be giving my body away for free for you
know for free or anything and then they
maybe misconstruing it and and ending up
on a lot of these sites you know I think
we just don't know some of the byproduct
of you know of some of these big
movements sometimes yeah you know it's I
don't know much about the world of the
the seeking arrangement I think was the
website yeah that whole thing always
seemed I don't know I don't know it's
like hopefully you hope it's a mutually
but I guess safe agreements
yes risky how can you cook how can you
control that yeah that's rescue man it's
just and look yeah it's very
sad I mean obviously no one thinks that
it's entertaining or funny you know what
happened to this young lady and and it's
very sad but you know yeah it's like I
mean you know you just wonder like if if
like you know some higher presence is
using her to help you know a lot of you
know maybe tens of thousands of other
girls you know stay safe you know very
true very well said yeah absolutely
well you're one of the funniest and most
talented guys that I know man everybody
I met at Barstow importantly knows how
to hire that is for damn sure thanks
brother
yeah it's it's good to talk to you man
love love what you're doing you're one
of the most unique people I've ever met
and looking forward to seeing you again
soon my man yeah same here man I'll be
in touch soon man you got to come into a
some weekend with me or something
hell yeah absolutely appreciate it all
right thanks Francis have a good one man
you talk peace Brett and that's him
right there Francis from barstool you
know really I mean an eloquent smart guy
and man he'd probably bout six foot five
but I think about 40% of it is heart the
guy's got a big heart and you know just
to be right there learn from his mistake
or you know learn from even what other
people say is your mistake fine I'm
gonna learn from it no matter what
instead of fighting the tide you know
instead of being just a salmon that
don't really have a plan but he keeps
swimming against the current he just
said I'm gonna ride it you know I'm
never sit here and stay in the current
and just think